all right before we get started want to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by
raycon the slick stylist true wireless
earbuds that yes
remain my workout earbuds which as
always and as demonstrated have yet to
fall out of my head
bang over important to note because i
use them for cardio because when you're
doing cardio
you need music it's long raycon earbuds
offer six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating
fit and they come in a variety of fun
colors no dangling wires or stems so
they're stylish and discreet and even
more discreet if you're rocking 20 20
hair
and since we're coming up on the season
of giving 2020 is going to give a little
back click the link below go to buy
reykong.com
john's and save yourself 20 off your
purchase but that offer is only for a
limited time so if you're looking for a
christmas or otherwise holiday gift
raycon earbuds small enough to go into
the stocking
cool enough to go under the tree and
they have a 45 day free return policy so
i'll take that so again click the link
below save 20
limited time those are your cliff notes
and thank you once again to raycon for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
all right now we're on to talking about
the continuing adventures of mando
and his really adorable space gremlin
i don't care if we eat eggs like chicken
eggs here on earth if chickens were
sentient beings that you know booked
passage
and contemplated their place in the
universe you know if they were
intellectually
on the level of human beings we would
probably not be eating their eggs in
fact we'd probably
rework the entire definition of
cannibalism which right there i feel
like this is
more insight into the mindset of baby
yoda it's only cannibalism if we're
equals
still adorable though so mando once
again
every episode this happens i feel like
this is it's like south park killing
kenny at this point someone or a group
of people in every episode they're going
to try to get
or kill the uh adorable mass murdering
space goblin in this episode
that was actually really intense this
group of pirates they were just like yep
pink and they hit his little carriage
baby carriage floating egg
into this body of water and this thing
just came up and ate it this thing's
like look frodo got away from me
but not baba yaga did a group of
mandalorians show up including but not
limited to
beau katan played by katie sakhoff we
love katy sacko and she's searching for
an
artifact that someone has which right
there you're like
you mean the dark saber that moth gideon
has
we all knew what it was going to be but
i'm glad to see it i'll tell you why in
a bit point is they take off their
helmets putting that to rest because
it that is the thing right it's been a
question why have we seen other
mandalorians take off their helmets but
in this world of mandalorian no that's
what you can't do that so i guess the
mandalorians like anything any religion
faction
fandom it has split you have this group
over here they're like ah you know
we're mandalorians but we can take off
the helmets it's fine then you have this
group over here and they're just like
i've never renounced the old ways which
kind of makes mando
in this show bit of a religious nut at
least he
he belongs to a group of religious nuts
so mandel's like all right i gotta help
beau kattan and her friends
uh infiltrate this imperial ship she
knows where i can find the jedi so i'm
gonna help her out and she's gonna help
me out it's gonna be a thing can't take
baby yoda on this adventures okay i'm
gonna leave
baby yoda here with the parents and the
food i mean it turns out to be fine
because in the end like the eggs are
hatching a little baby otto's like oh
so he's not eating them i suppose he he
sees them
as people now in any case though it
turned out fine i still feel like that's
like going hey
all right well i found a clown for the
birthday party meet john wayne gacy i'm
sure it'll be fine
this time regardless it turned out to be
fine
so they think you know that family of
geckos slash frogs slash
they're not either because they're not
from earth you know they're missing a
couple children
they just don't know it so going on to
the infiltration mission of this
small imperial vessel that they're just
gonna take over
as sled by smoke monster from lost and
some pretty dumb imperials and there's a
scene where our mandalorian friends
are gonna cut through this door and
they're just like all right stand in the
middle of this hallway
we're gonna hold them off i'm like take
cover guys there's all these crates
around them i'm like behind any of the
crates would
probably be fine i mean the crates were
filled with weapons i guess
it's not the safest spot i just i feel
like it's still safer than
a blaster bolt at the chest if i'm a
betting man well one of the reasons i
like this episode is because it shows
how hardcore moff gideon is he just
he's like if they've taken that much of
the ship you know what to do and the
commander's just gonna
nosedive it and crash the ship long live
the empire they say it shows that
this rabble of imperial survivors
they're just
they wanna hold on to the empire and
they're just willing to do whatever's
necessary
and that's just to me more interesting
than
first order but also bokeh tan is like
okay thank you for the help you're going
to go to this place
look for ahsoka tano and she'll help you
out which is a pretty big deal and all
these things come together
to make this the episode of mandalorian
that this season really needed
i know like mandalorians this episodic
adventure and
i accept it and i try my best to be okay
with it
for as long as i possibly can but it
does get kind of frustrating when it's
too episodic because
mandalorian has the potential to be that
show that my entire week revolves around
right like we've all had those shows
this could be that but it's not it's
just like this
episodic romp and i was gonna bring it
up last week but i was like let me see
what episode three of this season has
and episode three is the one that's like
okay we're delving into bigger things
now i mean possibly i mean it could
still be just this
episodic thing but i like the fact that
we're at least
getting a bit of the world of star wars
that does exist
and is out there season one ended with
all right here's the dark saber moff
gideon's pretty awesome oh by the way
you gotta go find the jedi it looks like
this season's finally picking up that
torch mandalorians like it's like that
relationship where it's like i love you
but maybe we should spice it up a bit
you know the talk
all right we've been together for a
while i'm really enjoying our time
together
um but if you want to no pressure but
if you feel the urge if we want to spice
it up a bit
i wouldn't hate it you know like i would
totally be down for it that's what i'm
here to let you know but like i said i'm
enjoying our time together
i mean i love you i baby where you going
but to that point i feel like this
episode probably could have been the
season two premiere yeah you'll have to
reshuffle a couple
things but mando could have just found
this gecko lady he was like oh hey my
husband knows
who can help you find the jedi and then
there we go we're on to
this episode but i did like this episode
short yes but
as it is still the formula of all right
going out on a half an hour adventure
this week it did its part to
build the overall plot and that's what i
like in a show and that's what this
episode delivered so all in all
this was the episode this season needed
and with them bringing in ahsoka
as long as they don't jake skywalker her
i think they have a good shot at making
this pretty awesome all right so season
two episode three of the man delorean
have you seen it why did you think about
it whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you